Tomoyo is obedient, or rather shy. She
wants to talk to her, but she can't. She's not very good at
talking to people, but in that case, she just needs to
practice. She's able to talk properly with Rian and the others.
Then, Veronica confronts Hirome with her family circumstances.  I know I'm
being told to do that, but
that's what I wanted to hear.I'm still not very good at it.Of
course I know, but I can't help it.I
heard that Veronica's house can be used by Sargent as a standing guard, so I'll do
something about it on my orders.  I guess that's what will happen, Mr.
Tomoyo
Magician.As descendants of magicians, you can be bound by something.You are
bound to your home from the moment you are born.No
matter how much this world sings of freedom, you will
not be forgiven.  The thing is, it's in the shadows. It
hurts a lot if you poke your head in that kind of thing easily.
I've also seen the pain of stepping inside someone I know.
[Music] Hey, you're a
hothead. Hey, yeah, that's what I'm
feeling.
Well, let's talk a little while we walk
[music]
KaM